vous êtes également aujourd'hui
ambassadeur à l'unesco vous vous
consacrez au programme éducatif de la
nasa vous essayez de favoriser l'accès à
l'enseignement pour les enfants du mali
et plus généralement pour tout le
continent africain ce qui va suivre a
été tourné dans votre pays a ses goûts
une ville que vous connaissez bien
depuis une quinzaine d'années une
nouvelle méthode d'éducation été mise en
place les enfants apprennent en
parallèle le français et leur langue
maternelle
reportage signé hélène verne et remy
poissonnier voici quinze ans casato est
enseignante à l'école de sofara cette
même école où elle a autrefois grande et
étudier mais son époque seuls 15% des
enfants étaient scolarisés
tout au plus une quarantaine par classe
aujourd'hui à sato enseigne à plus de 95
élèves dès maintenant les pinceaux
si au mali l'éducation de base est
devenu une priorité du gouvernement
le taux d'échec reste dramatique seul un
élève sur quatre variantes au terme du
cursus car ces enfants apprennent tout
en français langue qu'ils ne parlent pas
à la maison pour lutter contre ces
difficultés une nouvelle méthode a été
développé en 1986 ici en première année
tous écrits tous ces noms sont bombard à
la longue régional mécanismes
d'apprentissage sont assez emballant
donc ça favorise et l'apprentissage de
la langue seconde chez nous qu'ils le
feront sa royale la princesse concilie
les longues traditionnelle est la langue
officielle le français on appelle ça la
pédagogie convergente terminer les cours
magistraux où l'élève n'avait pas son
mot à dire que vous même vous pensé de
la saison froide ici chez nous au mali
le groupe 1 entre le bon la saison
comme tout le monde tombe malade
les fans viennent à nouveau son elysées
question de notre habitude la première
année à poser des questions même souvent
quand les clous tableau si un des
petites gérer et aux élèves ne sont pas
le froid aux yeux de monsieur tel facile
est ce que vous êtes pas trompés
attentif éveillé
ces enfants-là participent à leur propre
formation ouais je suis vraiment
persuadé que ça peut faire du mali parce
que le propos qu'est ce que le malawi le
mali veut et malgré mes mains des
citoyens éclairés des citoyens
puisqu'ils n'ont pas de complexe du tout
à la des citoyens qui sont là alors
voulu payer donc cette musique on
présente d'abord prépare d'abord elle
occupe dont la méthode est efficace mais
elle est chère et nécessite de nouveaux
manuels des enseignants motivés
pourtant c'est le seul moyen pour ces
enfin d'accéder à la modernité sans
renoncer à la richesse de leurs
traditions et la méthode tchèque